>> WE HAVE TO MAKE IT HARDER
FOR PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO
PURCHASE WEAPONS.
WE HAVE PEOPLE KNOW ON TERRORIST
WATCH LISTS WHO CAN PURCHASE A
WEAPON.
>> I HAVE NO ISSUE WITH MORE
EXTENSIVE BACKGROUND CHECKS, NO
ISSUE WITH SLOWING DOWN
PURCHASES FOR PEOPLE WHO SHOW
THE WARNING SIGNS.
>> WE ARE GOING TO MAKE SCHOOL
SAFETY THE TOP PRIORITY.
WE'RE GOING TO WORK WITH
CONGRESS AND LEADERS AROUND THE
COUNTRY.
TO MORE EFFECTIVELY GIVE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS TO DEAL WITH
PEOPLE SUFFERING WITH DANGEROUS
MENTAL ILLNESS.
>> POLITICAL LEADERS ONE UNION
IN THE WAKE OF 17 STUDENTS
GUNNED DOWN IN FLORIDA, ONE OF
THE WORST SCHOOL SHOOTINGS WE'VE
SEEN.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL.
TOM BEVAN, REAL CLEAR POLITICS.
ANNE GEARAN.
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT "THE FEDERALIST."
WE HAVE REPUBLICANS SAYING
SOMETHING NEEDS TO CHANGE.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING IN THE
WAKE OF THIS.
WE HEARD SIMILAR LANGUAGE AFTER
THE LAS VEGAS SHOOTING IN WHICH
REPUBLICANS SEEM TO SUPPORT THE
IDEA OF BANNING BOMB STOCKS.
ARMING GETTING CLOSE TO CRITICAL
MASS, THAT SOMETHING WILL
HAPPEN?
OR WILL BE TALKED ABOUT AND LIKE
WE HAVE SEEN THEY WILL FADE
AWAY.
>> HISTORY SUGGESTS THERE WILL
BE A MOMENT HERE LIKE THERE WAS
WITH BOMB STOCKS AND THEN IT
WILL GO AWAY.
THAT SAID, I THINK THIS REALLY
DOES FEEL LIKE THERE IS A
DIFFERENT CURRENT IN THE WATER.
I THINK WE SEE EVIDENCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP FEELS THERE IS
SOMETHING DIFFERENT ABOUT THIS
TIME TOO.
THE MAIN DIFFERENCE TO ME I
THINK IS THE KIDS.
IT IS REALLY HARD TO LOOK AWAY
AND REALLY HARD TO IGNORE 17,
18-YEAR-OLDS BLAMING ADULTS,
BLAMING THE PRESIDENT, BLAMING
THE POLITICAL SYSTEM, BLAMING
BOTH PARTIES FOR NOT DOING
ENOUGH.
IF THAT LEVEL OF ACTION AND
POLITICAL ENGAGEMENT CONTINUES,
IT'S GOING TO BE HARD FOR
EVERYONE TO LOOK AWAY.
>> John: TOM, CAN THESE
STUDENTS GO UP AGAINST THE
ENTRENCHED BELIEFS ON BOTH SIDES
OF THE AISLE IN WASHINGTON?
>> THEY CAN.
THEY ARE EFFECTIVE COMMUNICATORS
FOR THEIR CAUSE.
THE PROBLEM IS WITH THESE
INSTANTS, WE SEE IN HINDSIGHT
WHAT WE SHOULD'VE SEEN IN
FORESIGHT.
INTERESTING FACT.
THE LAST THREE MASS SHOOTINGS IN
FLORIDA, OMAR MARTIN, PULSE
NIGHTCLUB.
FORT LAUDERDALE AIRPORT
SHOOTING, JANUARY 2017 AND THIS
ONE.
ALL THREE PERPETRATORS WERE ON
THE RADAR OF THE FBI.
IN FACT, THE ONE WHO SHOT UP THE
FORT WORTH AIRPORT WENT TO THE
FBI OFFICE AND SAID HE WAS BEING
MIND CONTROLLED BY THE CIA.
SAID THESE CRAZY THINGS AND
STILL MANAGE TO GET A GUN, GOING
DO THIS.
THE FBI I THINK REALLY DID DROP
THE BALL NOT JUST IN THIS
INCIDENT BUT OTHERS.
WE HAVE THE DOTS.
THEY ARE THERE BUT WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO CONNECT THEM.
>> John: MOLLIE, ONE OF THE
BIG QUESTIONS IS WHERE DOES
PRESIDENT TRUMP COME DOWN ALL
THIS AND WHERE IS THE
APPROPRIATE ROLE?
LET'S HEAR WHAT JOHN KASICH
SAID.
>> WE NEED LEADERSHIP OUT OF THE
EXECUTIVE.
THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
COMMON SENSE STEPS THAT CAN BE
TAKEN.
IN THE AREA OF BACKGROUND
CHECKS.
OF COURSE THE PRESIDENT CAN LEAD
ON THIS AND SHOULD LEAD ON THIS.
>> John: THE PRESIDENT
SUPPORTS ENHANCED BACKGROUND
CHECKS BUT REALLY WHAT HE IS
SUPPORTING IS TO ENFORCE THE
LAWS ALREADY ON THE BOOKS TO
MAKE SURE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND STATES REPORT TO THIS AND
ICS CRIMINAL BACKGROUND CHECK
DATABASE.
THEY ARE NOT DOING NOW.
HOW MUCH LEADERSHIP ARE WE GOING
TO SEE?
>> PEOPLE WANT GOVERNMENT ACTION
AND IF THEY CARE ABOUT
GOVERNMENT ACTION, THERE IS
THESE.
THIS IS THE THIRD SHOOTING WHERE
THERE WAS GOVERNMENT FAILURE.
CHARLESTON CHURCH SHOOTING.
FAILURE TO PUT PEOPLE ON THE
LIST.
HERE YOU HAD MULTIPLE PEOPLE
GIVING SPECIFIC, CREDIBLE
ASSESSMENTS THIS GUY WAS GOING
TO DO WHAT HE DID.
RATHER THAN PUT NEW LAWS ON THE
BOOKS, A GREAT THING WOULD BE TO
MAKE SURE THE LAWS ON THE BOOKS
IS FAITHFULLY EXECUTED RATHER
THAN HAVE ANOTHER THING NOT
FOLLOWED.
>> John: SEEMS LIKE A SIMPLE
THING.
HERE'S WHAT THE LAW STIPULATED.
LET'S GET TOGETHER AND MAKE SURE
WE ARE FAITHFULLY ADHERING TO
THE LAWS AND SHARING THE
INFORMATION.
SEEMS LIKE A NO-BRAINER.
>> THE SYSTEM HAS A SOFT SPOT
WHICH IS STATES ARE NOT
COMPELLED TO TURN OVER THE
INFORMATION.
WHAT THE BILL WOULD DO IS ADD
INCENTIVES AND ENCOURAGEMENT TO
STATES SO YOU WOULD HAVE A
BETTER COLLECTION OF INFORMATION
BETTER COLLECTION OF INFORMATIO
INFORMATION.
IN THIS PARTICULAR INSTANCE, IF
THE FBI HAD FOLLOWED UP, IF A
FAIL-SAFES WHICH ARE NOT A LAW
HAD BEEN IN PLACE, THIS GUY
MIGHT'VE BEEN STOPPED BUT
THERE'S ONE LAW THAT WOULD HAVE
PREVENTED AT LEAST HIM DOING
EXACTLY WHAT HE ENDED UP
CARRYING OUT, AN ASSAULT WEAPON
BAN.
HE WAS ABLE TO LEGALLY BUY AN
AR-15 WHICH WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN
THE CASE 15 YEARS AGO.
THAT IS A HIGH HURDLE FOR
CONGRESS TO CONSIDER TAKING UP
THE ASSAULT WEAPONS BAN AGAIN
BUT YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR CALLS
FOR IT.
>> John: THE FBI IS BEING
CALLED OUT FOR MISSING A BIG
WARNING SIGNAL, FAILING TO
CONNECT THE DOTS.
OHIO GOVERNOR JOHN KASICH SAID
PEOPLE SHOULD BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT.
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN IN YOUR
ESTIMATION IF THE FBI IS TOLD
THERE IS A CREDIBLE THREAT
AGAINST A SCHOOL IN FLORIDA AND
NEVER PASSES THAT INFORMATION
ALONG.
>> SOMEBODY SHOULD BE SUSPENDED
OR LOSE THEIR JOB.
>> John: SHOULD THAT BE THE
FBI DIRECTOR?
>> OH, I DON'T KNOW WHAT HAS TO
BE THE FBI DIRECTOR BUT
CERTAINLY THE PEOPLE WHO FIELDED
THAT INFORMATION AND FAILED TO
PASS IT ON.
THEY DID NOT FOLLOW FBI
PROTOCOL.
THERE SHOULD BE CONSEQUENCES.
THE FBI COULD UNDERTAKE A
BROADER INVESTIGATION ABOUT THE
CASES I MENTIONED AND OTHERS.
WHY THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO CONNECT
THE DOTS.
THEY HAVE PEOPLE WHO HAVE ALL
THESE RED FLAGS AND WARNING
SIGNS.
OMAR MATEEN WAS ON A TERRORIST
WATCH LIST FOR TWO YEARS.
THE FBI CAN DO A LOT OF INTERNAL
INVESTIGATIONS AND PERHAPS COME